Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 32. Ausgabe von Forschergeist, unserer Gesprächsserie rund um Wissenschaft. Aber auch um wissenschaftliche Verantwortung für die Gesellschaft. Ein Thema, was jetzt hier in den letzten Folgen schon mehrfach durchgeklungen ist und was wir in gewisser Hinsicht auch heute wieder aufnehmen wollen, wo es mal um ein Projekt geht, was in gewisser Hinsicht ein wenig neben der Spur liegt. Sich mit der sozialen Realität außerhalb des universitären Geschehens beschäftigt und versucht, das ganze aber auch wiederum damit zu verbinde. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Michael Vogel, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Herr Vogel Sie sind aus Bremerhaven und dort an der Hochschule Bremerhaven, so heißt die auch korrekt ja? Für Tourismusmanagement und Betriebswirtschaftslehre unterwegs.
Genau. Mein Hintergrund ist Betriebswirtschaftslehre und Volkswirtschaftslehre und wie es das Schicksal so wollte, habe ich dann einige Jahre im TUI-Konzern verbracht. Und diese Praxiserfahrung reichte dann bereits, um ich für eine Professur in Tourismus zu qualifizieren. Ich war damals 2003, als ich die Professur angetreten habe, mit Sicherheit der einzige Professur für Tourismus weltweit, der noch nie ein Tourismuslehrbuch in der Hand gehabt hatte.
Aber es gab schon andere, die eine Professur für Tourismus hatten?
Ja also das gibt es. Ja so selten ist das nicht. Das Besondere möglicherweise ist, dass meine Professur im ersten Studiengang für Seetouristik, den es überhaupt gab, angesiedelt war. Also Tourismus mit Schwerpunkt Kreuzfahrten. Und auch da bin ich wieder Exot gewesen, ich hatte nie eine Kreuzfahrt gemacht und ich hatte auch nie was damit zu tun.
Warum nicht, es soll so schön sein?
Ja seither habe ich ein paar Dienstreisen gemacht. Aber im Grunde genommen ging es darum, dass sie jemanden brauchten, der relativ zupackend den Studiengang aufbauen würde. Ich war also der erste berufene und ein Jahr lang auch der einzige Professur. Da kann man sich vorstellen, wer so den Hochschulbetrieb von innen kennt. Ich war Vertreter meines Studiengangs in sämtlichen nur denkbaren Gremien, weil ich eben der einzige war. Und gleichzeitig musste ich dann meine ganzen Veranstaltungen vorbereiten, überhaupt mich mal einlesen in die Thematik die ich bis dahin einfach nur aus der Praxis kannte. Also wie gesagt, Studiengang Tourismus mit Schwerpunkt Kreuzfahrten. Eigentlich denke ich mal ist der Studiengang ein betriebswirtschaftlicher Studiengang, der sich einen Branchenschwerpunkt gegeben hat, um für Studierende attraktiver zu sein.
Dann kann man an einer Branche vertiefter betriebswirtschaftliche und damit verbundene Fragestellungen sich angucken als wenn man morgens Forschung und Entwicklung, mittags Produktion, nachmittags Qualitätsmanagement im Dienstleistungsbereich, wie häufig in anderen betriebswirtschaftlichen Studiengängen. Bei uns ist es dann eher konsistent durchgehend alles wird anhand von Tourismus- und Kreuzfahrtthemen durchdekliniert. Und ja das bringt uns eigentlich schon relativ nah an eines meiner großen Anliegen seit eh und je eigentlich, das ist Lernen. Ich habe immer sehr gerne selber gelernt und habe auch meine Studienzeit entsprechend lange ausgedehnt. Ich war ausgesprochen gerne Student.
Habe nach der Betriebswirtschaftslehre einen Master in Umwelt und Ressourcenökonomie draufgesetzt, obwohl ich das hätte gar nicht machen müssen. Dann habe ich nochmals promoviert in theoretischer Volkswirtschaftslehre. Also Sie sehen, das bereitet einen wirklich gut auf eine Karriere in Tourismus vor.
Warum denn überhaupt Betriebswirtschaftslehre? Hat ja auch so einen merkwürdigen Ruf.
Ja genau. Also bei mir, weil ich immer gerne gelernt habe, auch im formalen System Schule. Konnte ich in der Oberstufe eigentlich alles machen. Ich war gut in Chemie und Physik und in Fremdsprachen und in Deutsch und habe dann mir für meinen beruflichen Werdegang überlegt, ich möchte gerne nicht in einem Labor, in so einem Keller oder so was mein Dasein fristen, sondern ich möchte gerne raus und gerne unter Menschen und ich möchte auch die Möglichkeit haben, im Ausland mal zu arbeiten und die Möglichkeit haben, Geld zu verdienen. Und irgendwie fielen so nach und nach eine ganze Reihe von Studienrichtungen damals weg und wie es halt so ist, als Schüler weiß man sowieso nicht, was auf einen zukommt im Studium. Und ich habe mich dann ein bisschen danach orientiert, was in meinem Freundeskreis die Themen waren. Und das waren damals Jura und Betriebswirtschaftslehre.
Mein Vater war Jurist und deswegen kam das nicht für mich in Betracht und so habe ich BWL angefangen ohne Leidenschaft. Also das hat sich auch nicht wirklich geändert. Ich glaube kaum jemand entschließt sich, Betriebswirtschaftslehre aus Leidenschaft zu studieren.
Ja den Eindruck hat man langsam manchmal. Aber könnte das nicht auch sein?
Ja, also Betriebswirtschaftslehre, so wie es im Wöhe-Lehrbuch steht ist glaube ich leidenschaftsfrei. Also da lässt sich nicht viel machen. Aber die Art, wie man studieren kann, daran lässt sich recht viel tun. Und das treibt mich eigentlich sehr stark um. Ich beschränke mich vielleicht jetzt auch auf wirtschaftswissenschaftliche Studiengänge, weil es die sind, die ich eigentlich am besten kenne, über Geisteswissenschaften kann ich nichts sagen oder Naturwissenschaften. Leute, die später im Unternehmen vielleicht auch Verantwortung übernehmen möchten, die Entscheidungen treffen müssen, die möglicherweise die Leben von vielen anderen Leuten betreffen und mit einem ökonomischen Blick an Probleme, an Fragestellungen herangehen, die können auch anders als in Entscheidungstheorie auf diese Rolle vorbereitet werden.
Und wir haben ja in Deutschland schon länger die Diskussion, ob es zum Beispiel bestimmte Studiengänge gibt, die besser prinzipiell an Fachhochschulen aufgehoben sind, weil sie einfach nur Berufspraxis vorbereiten und nicht eine wissenschaftliche Laufbahn. Und Betriebswirtschaftslehre wäre sicherlich ein Studiengang, den ich dort ansiedeln würde. Und die Fachhochschulen haben die Möglichkeit, sehr viel praxisnäher und vielleicht auch ein Stück weit praxissimulierender oder tatsächlich praktischer zu funktionieren. Seit meiner Berufung da an die Hochschule Bremerhaven und sagen wir mal nach den ersten zwei Jahren, in denen ich nun gekämpft habe, um meine Vorlesungen vorzubereiten und wenigstens ein paar Stunden Vorsprung vor den Studierenden zu haben, ab da habe ich immer wieder Experimente unternommen in der Lehre mit dem Ziel, den Studierenden Freiräume zu schaffen, in denen sie sich selbst ausprobieren können.
Eine Methode, die sich bei mir als sehr wirksam erwiesen hat ist problembasiertes Lernen. Da ist meine Rolle als Lehrender, nur ein Szenario zu schildern, das möglicherweise mit einem oder vielen Problemen durchsetzt ist und einen Prozess zu definieren, anhand dessen die Studierenden mit dieser Problemsituation sich beschäftigen sollen. Das sieht dann so aus, dass die Studierenden in Teams erst mal überlegen, haben wir eigentlich verstanden was in dem Text vor sich geht? Welche Begriffe haben wir nicht verstanden oder welche Zusammenhänge haben wir nicht verstanden? Und was müssen wir tun, um es zu verstehen? Erstmal zu erkennen, was man nicht weiß. Das ist eine sehr wichtige Sache, die wird im Studium in der Regel unterschätzt. So dann werden Aufgaben verteilt innerhalb der studentischen Teams. Wer informiert sich über was und referiert hinterher, so dass beim nächsten Treffen das Team insgesamt in die Lage versetzt wird, die Ausgangssituation zu verstehen und vielleicht schon Probleme zu erkennen. Probleme zu definieren.
Und naja jedes Team liest in einer gegebenen Situation ein ganz anderes Problem hinein oder heraus. Da sieht man schon diesen typische Fallstudienansatz, der in betriebswirtschaftlichen und Managementstudiengängen verbreitet ist. Wo dann ein 12-seitiger Text vorgegeben wird und irgendwo ist dann total offensichtlich, wo das Problem liegt und dann hat man 45 Minuten, um dieses Problem zu lösen. So funktioniert problembasiertes Lernen nicht, sondern es ist eher unstrukturiert. Die Probleme sind größer als das was die Studierenden auf Anhieb erfassen können. Eigentlich werden sie überfordert und müssen kämpfen, um mit dem Problem, das sie überfordert, zurechtzukommen. Und darin besteht eigentlich ein ganz wichtiger Lerneffekt. Nicht nur das Fachwissen, das sie sich auf die Weise aneignen, sondern auch die Fähigkeit mit unstrukturierten, miteinander verwobenen, konfusen Situationen umzugehen.
Und dann auch noch ein Team, wo unterschiedliche Meinungen aufeinanderprallen, da einem gemeinsamen systematischen Lösungsweg zu folgen. Und zum Schluss für ein selbstdefiniertes Problem Lösungsalternativen gefunden zu haben, sie bewertet zu haben und sich schließlich begründet für einen Lösungsansatz entschieden zu haben.
Ich merke schon, Sie gehen da sehr analytisch an das ganze Thema ran. Mich würde jetzt nochmal gerne so die inhaltliche Komponente auch nochmal interessieren, die sich jetzt hier konkret abzeichnet. Bremerhaven, der Name sagt es schon, eine Stadt mit Blick aufs Meer. Jetzt haben wir hier noch so einen Kreuzfahrtstudiengang, sage ich mal ganz salopp.
Für den nicht eingeweihten mag das so klingen, als ob das eine Traumlage sei, am Meer und mit Kreuzfahrten und so. Aber Bremerhaven ist gleichzeitig eine der ärmsten Kommunen Deutschlands. Führt regelmäßig in Statistiken über Kinderarmut, Arbeitslosigkeit, minderjährigen Schwangerschaften … Also quasi viele viele Armutsindikatoren, in denen ist Bremerhaven ganz ganz oben. Der Hintergrund ist, dass seit dem Zusammenbruch der deutschen Fischerei, Bremerhaven war Deutschlands größter Fischereihafen, seit dem Zusammenbruch der Werftenbranche in den 80er Jahren und seit auch der Verkleinerung der Bundeswehr und der Marine, dem Abzug vieler amerikanischer Truppen, Bremerhaven einfach einen wirtschaftlichen Rückschlag nach dem anderen erlebt hat.
Bremerhaven war früher eigentlich relativ wohlhabend, aber davon ist heute leider nichts mehr übrig. Und das führt zu einem interessanten Spannungsfeld in Bremerhaven. Auf der einen Seite gibt es ein Kreuzfahrtterminal und es gibt Werften, die spezialisiert auf den Ausbau von Kreuzfahrtschiffen, die Reparatur von Kreuzfahrtschiffen. Also man sieht fast immer, vor allen Dingen im Sommerhalbjahr, 1-3 Kreuzfahrtschiffe in Bremerhaven liegen. Und gleichzeitig hat man eben die großen sozialen Probleme und das Land Bremen an sich ist ja schon chronisch in Haushaltsnot. Und die Stadt Bremen, der geht es wirtschaftlich immer noch besser als Bremerhaven, also Bremerhaven hängt am Tropf von Bremen und Bremen hängt am Tropf des Länderfinanzausgleichs. Da macht man sich dann vielleicht so ein bisschen ein Bild.
Kommen denn die Studenten an der Hochschule Bremerhaven auch aus Bremerhaven oder aus dem unmittelbaren Umfeld?
Ich glaube es ist sehr stark studiengangsabhängig. Die Hochschule versucht, wegen ihrer Randlage auch, Nischenstudiengänge anzubieten, die es sonst nirgendwo gibt oder nur selten gibt, um Leute von weit her anzulocken. Und mein Studiengang, der Seetouristikstudiengang beispielsweise war weltweit einzigartig, bzw. wir glaubten er sei weltweit einzigartig, zeitgleich hat in Plymouth auch einer begonnen, aber das haben wir erst drei Jahre später festgestellt. Aber trotzdem wenn man einen Standortnachteil hat, dann muss man den kompensieren. Es gibt natürlich auch so eine Art Grundversorgung mit Studiengängen. Also Betriebswirtschaftslehre ganz normal gibt es da auch oder Informatik ganz normal gibt es da auch. Aber viele andere Studiengänge, die sind sehr speziell, Schiffsbetriebstechnik oder maritime Technologien, also Offshore-Windkraft, das findet man eigentlich sonst nirgendwo als Studiengang.
Und das ist schon eine Chance auch an der Stelle?
Das ist auch ganz ganz klar die Aufgabe der Hochschule. Es gibt eigentlich kaum sonst einen Mechanismus, über den die Stadt Bremerhaven junge, vielleicht ideenreiche, Leute mit guter Ausbildung oder so nach Bremerhaven holen kann. Die Hochschule ist eine der ganz ganz wenigen Chancenträger und entsprechend gehen wir da auch bei der Studiengangsentwicklung vor. Wir gucken uns schon sehr genau an, was es woanders gibt und was es für „Marktpotenzial“ es für Studierende da geben könnte, um da nicht sofort in Wettbewerb zu stehen mit Hamburg. Wo wir natürlich wegen des Standorts immer sofort den Kürzeren ziehen würden.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt gar keine Studenten aus dem Umland da wären?
Also ich habe jetzt die Statistik nicht genau vor Augen, aber ich denke mal zwei Drittel der Studierenden, der 3.000 Studierenden, sind aus dem Umland und ein Drittel von außerhalb. Ud das ist für Bremerhaven, ein Drittel sind immer noch 1.000, das ist schon ein Faktor. Denn gerade Studierende in Ingenieurwissenschaften, Bremerhaven hat überwiegend technische Studiengänge, von denen bleiben schon viele kleben, die dann im Verlauf des Studiums bereits angefangen haben, in der Region für ein Unternehmen zu arbeiten und dann hinterher übernommen werden. Gerade bei Fachhochschulen sind ja Praktika Gang und Gäbe und daraus ergeben sich sehr häufig schon künftige Arbeitsbeziehungen. Und was ich mir eigentlich immer noch wünsche für Bremerhaven wäre ein Studiengang, der gezielt auf Unternehmensgründung hin arbeitet, damit der Studierende auch mit dem eigenen Unternehmen die Region noch bereichern kann. Aber da sind wir noch nicht ganz.
In unserer vierten Ausgabe hier bei Forschergeist hatten wir ja das Thema Talentförderung, haben wir mit Suhat Yilmaz gesprochen von der westfälischen Hochschule, der halt gerade auch dieses spezifische Problem im Ruhrgebiet angesprochen hat, dass es eben auch viele Bevölkerungsgruppen gibt, auch aber nicht nur Familien mit Einwandererhintergrund, wo einfach aus der sozialen Entwicklung heraus, die ja auch durch einen Mangel an wirtschaftlicher Entwicklung über lange Zeit geprägt ist, sich vor allem auch viele überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen konnten, überhaupt in die Hochschulen zu gehen. Ist das auch ein Problem, was existiert und vielleicht auch adressiert wird an Ihrer Hochschule?
Ich glaube das ist ein bundesweites Thema. Seit die Politik die Devise ausgegeben hat, den Anteil Studierender an einem Altersjahrgang zu steigern auf bis zu 50%, heute sind wir da glaub ich bei 40 oder so, auf jeden Fall ganz zentrales Thema die Studierenden mit den sogenannten nicht traditionellen Werdegängen. Das sind solche, die sogenannte Studienpioniere, die ersten in ihrer Familie sind, die an eine Hochschule gehen, die werden sehr sehr stark umworben, nicht nur in Bremerhaven, das ist glaub ich überall. Der Stifterverband beispielsweise hat die Hochschule ausgezeichnet für ihr Studienpioniere-Programm, das halt Brückenangebote schafft, um die Schwellenangst zu vermindern. Studienpioniere werden auch unterstützt in dem ersten Studienjahr durch Studierende, die schon ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung haben. Es gibt Stammtische dafür. Also da wird schon einiges gemacht.
Dann haben wir, ich glaub auch wie andere Hochschulen, das Thema Geflüchtete oder auch Migranten aus 1. oder 2. Generation, wo teilweise auch die Deutschkenntnisse noch nicht so da sind, auch dafür gibt es spezielle Unterstützungskurse. Es gibt studentische Initiativen an der Hochschule Bremerhaven, die sich speziell um neuankommende studierfähige und studierwillige Geflüchtete kümmern. Auch da können wir noch sehr viel mehr machen, aber das ist eigentlich ein aufregendes Thema, das in vielerlei Hinsicht Hochschule auch in Frage stellt. Die Art wie wir lernen und arbeiten nehmen wir sowieso selbstverständlich. Und wenn dann Geflüchtete aus ganz anderen Ecken der Welt kommen, die in einem anderen System groß geworden sind und dann ganz irritiert auf unseres blicken, dann sehen wir erst wie speziell und unbewusst wir bestimmte Traditionen fortschreiben.
Also ich sehe das persönlich als eine große Chance. Auf Englisch Lehre durchzuführen ist inzwischen kein großes Thema mehr, das passiert ohnehin. Auch weil Bremerhaven versucht, Austauschstudierende aus dem Ausland anzulocken oder für Masterstudiengänge auch gerade technikaffine Menschen aus der ganzen Welt nach Bremerhaven zu holen. Da ist eigentlich der Zusatzaufwand für Geflüchtete nicht so das Thema, es ist eher die Frage, wie kriegt man sie studierfähig auch auf englisch. Denn für viele ist auch englisch nicht erste oder zweite Sprache.
Aber belieben wir nochmal bei der Stadt Bremerhaven. Also wir haben jetzt dieses schwierige Umfeld. Wir haben einerseits das Bemühen der Hochschule, auch aktiv zur wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung der Region beizutragen. Was, wenn ich höre zwei Drittel kommen aus dem Umfeld, ja auch so schlecht nicht funktioniert. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sozusagen alle nur noch aus der Ferne kommen würden, sondern die, die quasi durch die spezifischen Angebote noch angelockt werden, ergänzen das sozusagen.
Ja die spezifischen Angebote sind auch eher kleinere Studiengänge, Nischenstudiengänge, Nischenangebote sind ja nicht Massenbetrieb. Ja klar. Also ich denke mal, erst einmal geht es darum, dass in der Region Bildungsangebot da ist, damit die Leute die groß werden in der Region Bremerhaven, dass die nicht weg müssen, sondern da bleiben können. Das ist ja schon mal ein erster Schritt. Und dann Grund für Studierende von anderswo zu schaffen, nach Bremerhaven zu kommen, das ist eine zweite Rolle und natürlich durch Forschung und Entwicklung in Zusammenarbeit mit Branchen in der Region, Innovationen zu fördern und dergleichen, auch das ist die klassische Aufgabe natürlich von Hochschulen. Und Fachhochschulen haben speziell die Aufgabe, einer engen Verzahnung mit der Region den Vorzug zu geben.
Deswegen hat die Hochschule Bremerhaven ein stark maritimes Profil, dass auf Offshore-Windenergie, auf Schiffbau, Schilfbetrieb und natürlich auch Seetouristik eingeht. Also dieser Bezug, der steht im Hochschulprofil und der wird sehr ernst genommen.
Trotzdem hatten Sie jetzt den Eindruck, dass noch mehr Realitätsbezug im Studium angemessen gewesen wäre, wenn ich das mal so salopp formulieren darf?
Ja. Der seetouristische Studiengang in Bremerhaven begann 2003 und 2006 stellten meine Kollegen und ich fest, eigentlich zu unserer Überraschung, dass es so lange gebraucht hat, stellten wir fest, wie sehr die Studierenden, die nach Bremerhaven kommen, wie völlig fokussiert die auf das Thema Tourismus sind. Die haben einen romantischen Lebensentwurf, die möchten später dort arbeiten, wo andere Leute Urlaub machen oder sie möchten in einer Branche arbeiten, die anderen Leute zumindest die schönsten Tage im Jahr ermöglicht. Also eigentlich nicht besonders materiell geprägte Studienmotivation, sondern eine Lifestyle-Entscheidung könnte man sagen, Tourismus zu studieren. Das ist überall so.
Aber der völlige Fokus auf Tourismus und die Begeisterung für die Branche und all das verdrängte völlig, zumindest in den Diskussionen, die wir so mitkriegten, die Wahrnehmung der Studierenden ihres Umfelds. Nämlich des wirklich schwierigen Bremerhavener wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Umfelds. Und da sagten wir, Mensch das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein, dass die Hochschule wie eine Insel ist und was drumherum passiert, das lassen wir nicht rein.
Wie eine Urlaubsinsel.
Ganz genau oder ein Kreuzfahrtschiff ganz genau. Interessante Metapher. Und naja wir haben uns überlegt …
Also ich meine, ich halte das für nachvollziehbar in gewisser Hinsicht.
Aus studentischer Sicht schon.
Weil man ausbrechen möchte und man will sich sozusagen von dieser tristen Realität ein wenig entfernen und dann sieht man halt das Studium und dann kommt dann auch noch irgendwie Tourismus und Fernreisen und all diese großen Boote, die da immer parken und die man vielleicht auch schon so oft gesehen hat, dann eben auch mal konkret zu bespielen, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das so ein Reiz auch ist, sich dann darin auch ein wenig zu verlieren. Und das andere auch ein wenig vergessen zu wollen.
Ich meine nicht anders ist es, wenn jemand Informatik studiert und Informatik liebt und Tag und Nacht und bei jeder Gelegenheit mit Kumpels über Programmierung oder irgendwelche Umgebungen oder so spricht. Das ist eben einfach so. Nur das war uns nicht genug und das macht es auch nicht richtiger. Ich denk die Hochschulen haben nicht nur die Rolle, ihre Studierenden auf den Beruf vorzubereiten. Das ist durch die Bologna-Reformen, durch all das  was mit Bachelor-/Mastereinführung geschehen ist, da hat es schon sehr stark diese Ausrichtung bekommen. Also die Berufsbefähigung, die sogenannte Employability, die steht schon sehr stark im Vordergrund. Und natürlich bei Studiengängen, die einen Branchenschwerpunkt haben wie Tourismus, also unbestritten.
Nochmal extra.
Ja. Nur die Gefahr ist einfach, wenn dieser Fokus so stark überhand nimmt, dass alles andere ausgeblendet wird, bei Leuten, die später im Beruf Entscheidungsverantwortung tragen durchaus, dann finde ich beginnt es problematisch zu werden. Und meine Kollegen und ich haben damals beschlossen, wir möchten, dass unsere Studierenden nicht nur beispielsweise auf Projekten für Tourismusunternehmen Praxiserfahrung sammeln, sondern wir haben die Mitarbeit in sozialen Projekten in Bremerhaven. Also ein Beitrag zu Bremerhaven als Pflichtbestandteil des Studiums eingeführt 2006. So ein bisschen zum Ausprobieren, mal gucken wie die Reaktion ist, das ist ja auch nicht ganz ohne Risiko. Aber es funktionierte sehr gut. Es haben sich gleich eine Vielzahl von Sozialeinrichtungen in der Umgebung interessiert gezeigt, Projekte anzubieten für Studierende.
Die Projekte liefen dann eigentlich recht gut. Man darf eben nicht vergessen, dass betriebswirtschaftliches KnowHow, also zum Beispiel die Fähigkeit in Kosten-Erlösen zum Beispiel zu denken, in Zielgruppenkategorien zu denken, Projekte zu strukturieren, zu organisieren, Finanzierungsseite mitzudenken und solche Dinge, diese Fähigkeiten werden nicht nur in Unternehmen, sondern natürlich auch in Sozialeinrichtungen und in Vereinen, die sich um soziales kümmern, genauso gebraucht. Und unsere Studierenden haben mit der gleichen Begeisterung, wie sie vielleicht für die TUI vielleicht ein Projekt gemacht haben, haben sie dann eben auch für soziale Einrichtungen in Bremerhaven mit Menschen mit geistigen oder körperlichen Behinderungen, oder Kinder aus Hartz IV Familien, Projekte durchgeführt.
Das lief echt super an, so gut eigentlich, dass mich dann ein bisschen der Übermut überkam. Ich habe mich dann gefragt, können wir nicht das Thema noch ein wenig weiter ausdehnen? Können wir nicht eine Lernumgebung schaffen, die wir selber stärker noch kontrollieren können, als sie es bei einer Sozialeinrichtung können? Und so hatte ich die Idee, ein Lernunternehmen ins Leben zu rufen, ein Lernunternehmen, das die Studierenden gestalten können, das aber gleichzeitig sich irgendwie an einem „Markt“ selbst behauptet, also unter realen Bedingungen. Und damit das Ganze noch einen gesellschaftlichen Mehrwert bietet dachte ich mir ein Sozialunternehmen für Studierende zum Lernen das wäre was. 2009 habe ich dann langem Grübeln beschlossen, ja das wäre spannend. Ich übernehme mal die Verantwortung dafür, dass es ein Jahr lang mit aufzubauen.
Habe dann Studierenden den Auftrag gegeben, eine Machbarkeitsstudie für ein Straßenmagazin für Bremen und Bremerhaven zu erarbeiten.
Was es noch nicht gab zu dem Zeitpunkt?
Ganz genau. Es gab in Bremen nur ein Straßenmagazin, Berliner Straßenfeger interessanterweise wurde in Bremen verkauft und das Magazin Asphalt aus Hannover, aber Bremen hatte komischerweise nie ein eigenes Straßenmagazin.
Das ist ja auch so eine Interessante Geschichte für sich diese Straßenmagazine, weil die ja im Prinzip auch aus diesem Gedanken der Eigenermächtigung heraus geboren wurden. Ich glaube das ging los in London mit „The big Issue“, was es glaube ich auch heute noch gibt. Und das war ja dann sozusagen dieses Konzept von, Leute, die auf der Straße leben müssen, berichten über ihre Situation, ihre Perspektive auch auf die Gesellschaft. Ich weiß gar nicht womit es anfing, aber heutzutage reflektieren ja diese Straßenmagazine nicht nur Probleme, sondern liefern ja auch einen neuen Blick auf die Gesellschaft, der eben vielleicht auch für potenzielle Käufer interessant ist, weil es ja nicht ihr Leben ist, was ansonsten beschrieben werden würde. Und es kam dann relativ schnell auch nach Deutschland. Wir hatten es schon Berlin etc. Nur Bremerhaven und Bremen fehlte da sozusagen noch die Eigenständigkeit?
Also nur kann man jetzt nicht sagen, es gibt schon noch Städte, die kein Straßenmagazin haben oder es gibt eine ganze Reihe Straßenmagazine, die überregional verkauft werden. Schleswig-Holstein hat Hempels, ein Straßenmagazin. Neuneumünster hat sein eigenes. Asphalt bedient ganz Niedersachsen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jede Stadt ein eigenes Straßenmagazin hat. Aber das interessante an „The Big Issue“ in London, tatsächlich das war in Europa das erste und das ist damals eingeschlagen, also es war sensationell erfolgreich. Als dann in Deutschland zum Beispiel in Hamburg „Hinz und Kunst“ ich glaube 93/94 gegründet wurde, die haben die ersten zwei Ausgaben achtmal nachdrucken müssen, weil die Nachfrage so groß war. Die haben mit der ersten Auflage über 100.000 Exemplare verkauft. Das schafft heute weit und breit überhaupt niemand mehr.
Das war also wirklich eine Zeit lang total hipp. In der Zwischenzeit haben sich die Straßenmagazine ein bisschen verändert. Auch die Gesellschaft hat sich ja sehr stark verändert. Aber die Idee ist immer noch, dass die Straßenmagazine einen Blick auf Gesellschaft an Perspektive anbieten, die sonst in den Medien nicht vertreten ist und denjenigen, die auf der Straße leben oder sich viel auf der Straße aufhalten, die dringend Geld brauchen, eine Möglichkeit bieten, durch wie eine berufliche Selbstständigkeit selbst zu entscheiden wie viel sie verkaufen und wann sie verkaufen. Also es ist keine Gängelei wie beim Amt. Prinzipiell erhalten die Verkäufer mindestens die Hälfte des Verkaufserlöses. Heute arbeiten eine ganze Reihe Straßenmagazinen mit professionellen Redaktionen. Und Bremen/Bremerhaven hatte eben kein eigenes Straßenmagazin, hat aber eine sehr starke Identität und da bot es sich eigentlich an.
Meine Idee war, dass Studierende das Straßenmagazin erstellen sollen als Lernprojekt und es dann von bedürftigen Leuten auf der Straße verkauft wird. Und auf die Weise hätten, stellte ich mir vor, würden eine ganze Reihe von Effekten ausgelöst werden. Studierende müssen sich mit Leuten auseinandersetzen, denen sie sonst vielleicht nie begegnen, also sich nie damit unterhalten. Da hatte ich die Vorstellung, dass auf die Weise Barrieren abgebaut werden. Dass auf die Weise auch eine Art Empathie entwickelt werden kann und auch Akzeptanz für völlig andere Perspektiven. Und das ist eingetreten. Ich dachte mir auch, dass Studierende, wenn sie eine Zeitschrift machen, ganz viel Gestaltungsspielraum haben. Man muss sich ja über tausend Jahre Gedanken machen.
Wie soll die aussehen, was soll der redaktionelle Schwerpunkt sein, wie wird sie vertrieben? Wie oft, wie organisiert man sie, wie finanziert man sie? Was für einen Organisationsrahmen braucht man dafür? Und all diese Fragen dachte ich werden dann von Studierenden diskutiert und gestaltet und möglicherweise regelmäßig umgestaltet. Genau so ging es dann. Wir haben dann Partner gesucht. In Bremen haben wir die Hochschule für Künste, für den Gestaltungsteil dazu. Eine große Sozialeinrichtung der Diakonie, der Verein als innere Mission kam als Herausgeber und Vertriebspartner dazu. Und Anfang 2011 erschien dann die erste Ausgabe der Zeitschrift. Und sie sah am Anfang die ersten Jahre aus eigentlich wie ein ganz hippes typografisch abgefahrenes, eigentlich sehr sehr anspruchsvolles, geradezu elitär gestaltetes Magazin, das mit Straße eigentlich nur den redaktionellen Schwerpunkt gemein hatte.
Der redaktionelle Schwerpunkt, jede Ausgabe widmet sich einer Straße. So dass die Käufer im Laufe der Jahre sich ihren journalistischen Stadtplan ihrer Heimatstadt sammeln können. Immer geschrieben aus einer Perspektive, die den Ausgangspunkt auf der Straße hat.
Das bringt ja den Begriff hyperlokal nochmal ins Extreme.
Also es ist radikal lokal. Monothematisch jede Ausgabe, genau einer Straße gewidmet. Die Zeitschrift heißt deswegen auch die Zeitschrift der Straße, nicht nur weil sie auf der Straße verkauft wird von Leuten, die auf der Straße leben, sondern auch weil sie sich mit Straßen beschäftigt oder mit Orten.
Plätzen genau.
Ganz genau. Also das war schon ein großes Abenteuer. Stellen Sie sich mal vor, nicht nur Studierende eines Studienganges machen das, sondern es braucht natürlich Journalismusstudenten für den journalistischen Teil. Es braucht Designstudierende. Es sind in der Laufe der Zeit noch Sozialpädagogikstudenten dazugekommen und Gesundheitswissenschaftler. Meine Seetouristiker. Und jetzt blicken wir schon auf 5,5 Jahre Zeitschrift der Straße zurück.
Bei den anderen Studiengängen kann ich es jetzt gerade gut nachvollziehen, warum die sich in diesem Projekt engagieren, aber was war denn die Rolle der Seetouristiker?
Naja Betriebswirtschaft.
Ach um den Laden sozusagen zu führen, das wirtschaftliche Projekt der Zeitung?
Ja genau, die Tourismusmanagementstudenten haben Schwerpunkte in den Bereichen Marketing  zum Beispiel, Projektmanagement, aber auch alles rund um Finanzierung, Organisation, Prozessorganisation und so weiter. All das kommt mit rein. Also Betriebswirte muss man eigentlich in beliebiges Umfeld setzen können und die müssten dann in der Lage sein, mit ihrem Handwerkszeug diesen Teil eines Problems zu bearbeiten. Und sind deswegen eigentlich prädestiniert interdisziplinär zu arbeiten, nur wird das an der Hochschule nicht vermittelt. Das war ein zweiter wünschenswerter Aspekt dieses Projekts. Einfach diese völlig idiotischen Disziplingrenzen von Hochschulen mal zu überwinden. So und da begann dann die Herausforderungen, mit denen wir gar nicht so gerechnet hatte.
Die Designstudierenden der Hochschule für Künste haben ganz ganz starke Dominanz entwickelt, weil waren eben der Auffassung, Design ist gleich Problemlösung. Das ist eigentlich das moderne Designverständnis. Und die Zeitschrift löst doch ein Problem, folglich sind wir für alles zuständig. Die Journalistik der Studierenden der Hochschule Bremen, also Sie merken schon, es sind gleich mehrere Hochschulen auch noch involviert, nicht nur Fachgebiete, die Journalistikleute haben natürlich gesagt, Moment, eine Zeitschrift, die designdominiert ist das geht nicht, wir müssen hier den Hut aufhaben. Das Bremerhavener Team hat gesagt, Moment wir werben hier Anzeigen ein, machen Fundraising, bringen das ganze Geld daher, mit dem ihr euch da selbst verwirklicht, so geht es nicht. Und dann war noch die Sozialeinrichtung, Verein für innere Mission, die sagt:
Moment, ihr habt es hier mit unserer Klientel zu tun, unserer Streetworker betreuen die, das ist unser Vertriebsbüro und wir sind Herausgeber, ihr könnt hier nicht machen was ihr wollt. Also das war bestimmt vier Jahre lang ein ständiges Ringen mit ganz ganz viel Lernerfahrung für alle Beteiligten da. Also bis heute haben insgesamt fünf Hochschulen, inklusive Uni Bremen, fünf Hochschulen mitgewirkt schon. Also das ist schon ziemlich ungewöhnlich und zwischen Bremen und Bremerhaven liegen ja nochmal 60km entfernt voneinander.
Und es ist eigentlich auch für jeden einzelnen Bereich eigentlich auch wirklich eine sehr interessante Herausforderung. Also den gestalterischen Teil hatten wir schon und ich kann das gut nachvollziehen, dass sich da gerade Gestalter erst mal auch total verrennen. Also man hat ein neues Projekt, da will man natürlich alles erst mal neu und toll und super machen. Und man ist ja ohnehin auch ein bisschen davon überzeugt, dass immer nur das allerneuste und beste überhaupt zum Erfolg führen kann, bis dann eben so die Realität einkickt und man feststellt, mh okay vielleicht sollten wir uns da doch mal über die Vermittelbarkeit sozusagen unserer Gestaltung Gedanken machen. Bzw. Die eigentliche Erkenntnis, und ich kenne das auch aus dem Softwarebereich und vielen anderen Bereichen auch, das was man meint, was irgendwie gut verständlich ist, weil man das selber so denkt, hat eben nicht zwingend was damit zu tun, wie andere Leute das aufnehmen. Und daran schärft man natürlich dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch seine Sinne und Fähigkeiten.
Indem man einfach ein Verständnis dafür entwickelt, kommt das auch an, was ich eigentlich mitteilen möchte. Und das ist ja dann eigentlich auch eine Botschaft fürs Lernen als solche, weil man ja immer eigentlich erst dann selber gut lernt, wenn man gut erklären kann. Das heißt in dem Moment, wo man eine Methode findet, die anderen wirklich unmittelbar zugänglich ist, bringt es einem eigentlich auch selber erst mal was.
Ja also so besser kann man es eigentlich kaum sagen. Die Schwierigkeit, wenn dann Hochschulen aufeinanderprallen mit verschiedenen Fachgebieten, da spielt auch immer noch so was wie ein ständiger empfundener Rechtfertigungszwang des eigenen Daseins eine Rolle. Die Designer möchten einfach die Gelegenheit nutzen und den Journalisten zeigen was sie drauf haben und die Journalisten möchten sich nicht von den ökonomischen Sachzwängen … Also dieses Ringen um Identität in so einem Umfeld ist einfach ganz stark ausgeprägt. Dann kommt noch hinzu, dass die Studierenden, die in so einem Projekt mitarbeiten, auch dafür Credits bekommen und benotet werden. Und gerade bei Design spielt schon eine Rolle, dass das was am Schluss gedruckt wird, so gestalterisch interessant ist.
Also nicht nur für den Menschen auf der Straße, der jetzt mit Gestaltung normalerweise nichts zu tun hat, der es irgendwie schön findet vielleicht, sondern das ist von einer professionellen Perspektive her ansprechend oder interessant oder wirksam oder irgendwie innovativ ist. Und das führt dazu, dass das Design das Risiko in sich trägt, zu abgehoben zu sein, um für den Rest der Bevölkerung zu funktionieren, weil es einfach für die Studierenden funktionieren muss. Und dieses Spannungsfeld das hatten wir lange Zeit nicht so gut im Griff. Und erst eigentlich als wir begonnen haben, Feedback von Verkäufern einzuholen oder von Kunden einzuholen, die dann vielleicht ein Foto auf einem Titelblatt vermisst haben, weil bei uns das ein rein typografisches Titelblatt war. Die sich irritiert gezeigt haben, warum da eine Perforation quer durchs Heft lief, die wir mittlerweile abgeschafft haben.
Aber es waren einfach einige Designelemente da, Text der quer zur Leserichtung gedruckt war, also vertikal. Dinge, die nirgendwo erklärt wurden, die echt super durchdacht haben wirklich, aber niemand erklärt es einem, schon gar nicht dem Kunden. Diese Sache haben wir dann mit der Zeit abgeschafft. Damit wurde das Projekt auch weniger interessant für Designer und die Hochschule für Künste hat sich dann auch deswegen im Sommer 2014 aus dem Projekt verabschiedet. Weil einfach dieses Spannungsfeld zwischen Designavantgarde und Straßenmäßigem und den vielen Beteiligten einfach zu groß geworden ist. Und seither haben wir eigentlich ein sehr viel konventionelleres, cleaneres und stabileres Design, das auch unsere Arbeitsprozesse kolossal vereinfacht, weil nicht mehr so viele Loopings und Hickups drin sind.
Aber es war trotzdem sicherlich auch wertvoll, durch diesen Prozess mal durchgegangen zu sein. Ich meine es ist jetzt in seinem Erscheinungsbild, ich halte jetzt hier gerade eine Ausgabe in der Hand, trotzdem noch sehr eigenständig. Erst mal von dem ungewöhnlichen Format, also ein extrem hochkantiges Heft. Eher so ein nach oben verlängertes DIN A5 Heft.
Genau es ist 33 cm hoch und 17,5 breit. Und das heißt es ist länger als A4 aber schmaler. Das ist eine der guten Ideen eigentlich gewesen, die wir aus dem Design beibehalten haben. In einem Kiosk würden wir uns mit diesem Format den Hass der anderen Zeitschriften zuziehen.
Weil es immer drübersteht.
Genau, im Regal die dahinterliegende Zeitschriften verdeckt würden. Auf der Straße dagegen ist es anders. Da sind wir die einzigen. Da stehen wir nicht in einem Wiedererkennungswettbewerb mit anderen Zeitschriften. Und die Wiedererkennung funktioniert hier ganz stark durch das Format. Und natürlich auch über andere Elemente, aber das Papierformat erlaubt es, auf eine Entfernung von 20 Metern zu erkennen, was da auf der Straße jemand in der Hand hält. Und das ist im Kiosk überhaupt kein Thema.
Na ich denke das arbeitet auch sehr gut für die Zeitschrift selber. Ist eine Zeitschrift oder Zeitung?
Ja doch Zeitschrift. Indem es halt auch viel Raum für Fotografien bietet, die irgendwie ganz gut wirken, also jetzt auf meinen ersten Eindruck. Ich finde es ein sehr schickes Design.
Ist eine Zeitschrift.
Gerade wenn man nicht gesagt kriegt, dass es ein Straßenmagazin ist, dann hält man es überhaupt nicht dafür.
Das stimmt.
Es weist in der Aufmachung überhaupt nichts darauf hin, dass es von Wohnungslosen auf der Straße verkauft wird. Das Papier ist sehr teuer und sehr hochwertig. Das ist unser größter Kostenblock. Da haben wir uns dafür entschieden, da mal richtig Geld in die Hand zu nehmen. Und innendrin ist es eigentlich relativ liebevoll. Mit viel Weißraum, übersichtlich gestaltet und nicht jeder Zentimeter ist voll. Auf jeden Fall ist für die Studierenden, die in dem Projekt mit dabei sind, eine wichtige Lernerfahrung eben dieses interdisziplinäre. Dass es Sichtweisen gibt, die legitim sind auch in einem Projekt, auch wenn es nicht die eigenen sind. Und dass es Kulturen gibt, Fachkulturen, die ganz anders sind und bei denen man halt einfach mal durchatmen muss und hinnehmen muss, dass es so ist. Das ist echt eine wichtige Erfahrung. Das haben wir an Hochschulen viel zu selten.
Eine weitere wichtige Erfahrung gerade für unsere Wirtschaftsstudenten, die nach dem Marketinglehrbuch glauben, wie verhalten sich Menschen ökonomisch rational, die entdecken dann in der Zusammenarbeit mit Leuten, die auf der Straße leben, die vielleicht Suchtprobleme haben oder alle möglichen multiplen Problemlagen miteinander verwoben haben, die verhalten sich teilweise völlig anders. An Tagen, wo zum Beispiel der Verkauf auf der Straße super läuft, wo jeder Ökonom sagen würde, prima heute mache ich Überstunden, dann verdiene ich das was ich brauche und noch viel mehr, da hören unsere Verkäufer umso früher auf. Ich habe meine 20 Euro für heute verdient, das reicht mir. Oder wir haben ein Jahr lang einen Veranstaltungskalender gepflegt, mit Veranstaltungen irgendwo in Bremen, Konzerte, Messen und so, Veranstaltungen bei denen es sich wahrscheinlich lohnen würde, sich als Verkäufer vor den Eingang zu stellen und zu verkaufen.
Und haben jeden Morgen im Vertriebsbüro den Verkäufern gesagt, schaut heute ist das und das, geht doch da mal hin. Da hat keiner jemals sich drum geschert.
Warum?
Weil ich weiß nicht, es gibt ganz starke Platzaffinität. Die haben dann ihren Standort, ihre drei Straßen, die sie kennen, wo sie sich auch sicher fühlen, wo dann die Geschäftsinhaber sie nicht vertreiben, wo sie einfach immer sind. Und da machen sie da einfach ihren Stiefel wie immer. Es ist also fast unmöglich, sie aus dem Alltagstrott rauszunehmen. Und das sind genau diese Erfahrungen, dieses nicht ökonomische Handeln, das für uns alle immer wieder eine völlige Überraschung und Lernerfahrung ist.
Interessant. Ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Weil gerade diese mangelnde Sicherheit in der Gesellschaft, die man dann eben in so einem lokalen Bereich sich in gewisser Hinsicht erwartet hat oder zumindest weiß, damit umzugehen, die Kneipen, die man kennt, die Leute, die man da immer wieder trifft.
Stammkunden ja.
Stammkunden etc., das ist dann irgendwie sehr viel mehr wert als dieses Wagnis, was wir überhaupt nicht als Wagnis abspeichern würden, aber nur mal an einem anderen Standort zu stehen und dort das Glück zu versuchen, das ist vielleicht für manche, die so lange auch aus den gesellschaftlichen Prozessen herausgehalten worden sind, ein viel größerer Schritt, den wir uns so gar nicht klarmachen.
Das krasseste Beispiel, wir haben gedacht eine Ausgabe über das Weserstadion, das muss doch der Renner sein. Also Bremen ist total Werder, also Werder Bremen ist absolut in der Gesellschaft verankert und deswegen das Weserstadion müsste doch ein totaler Selbstläufer sein und wenn dann Spiele sind oder auswärtige Gäste nach Bremen kommen, das muss doch laufen wie nix. Und dann haben wir dann gleich mal für eine Weserstadionausgabe letztes Jahr eine doppelt so große Auflage veranschlagt, wo wir gedacht haben, wir können uns gar nicht retten vor Nachfrage und das war total der Ladenhüter, also jetzt im Verhältnis zu dem was wir erwartet haben. Weil unsere Verkäufer eben nicht bei Spielen zum Weserstadion gegangen sind, um dort zu verkaufen, weil sie Angst haben vor betrunkenen Fußballfans, weil die eh so oft gesellschaftlich geprügelt werden, da haben wir überhaupt nicht dran gedacht.
Also der Verkauf lief wie immer, nur dass wir hinterher eine halbe Auflage, also eine Auflage im regulären Umfang übrig hatten.
Ich finde das an der Stelle, wenn man jetzt sozusagen die BWL-Perspektive mit rein nimmt, könnte man ja dann auch sagen, naja wenn jetzt die angestammten Verkäufer das nicht dort verkaufen wollen, dann könnte man es ja vielleicht auch mal über einen anderen Vertriebsweg probieren, damit es da eben dann auch verkauft wird. Ist so was erwogen worden und gemacht worden oder ist das dann ein Tabu?
Also in Bremerhaven zum Beispiel hat die Zeitschrift nie fußgefasst, weil dort die Wohnungslosigkeit eine ganz andere Struktur hat. Bremerhaven hat eigentlich viel Wohnraum. Also wenn man arm ist, kriegt man trotzdem eine Wohnung. Die Leute, die vielleicht auf der Straße leben, das sind entweder gestartete Seeleute, die vom Schiff gegangen sind in Bremerhaven und nicht wissen wie es weitergeht und Jugendliche, die von zu Hause ausgebüchst sind und sich mit Kleinkriminalität über Wasser halten. Und für beide Gruppen ist das Thema Straßenzeitung nichts. Und ansonsten herrscht wahrscheinlich in Bremerhaven, Bremerhaven hat jetzt 110.000 Einwohner, herrscht vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Scham, um sich öffentlich hinzustellen und zu sagen, hier ich verkaufe die Straßenzeitung, ich bin arm! Ein bisschen was ist da ja schon damit verbunden, wenn man sich da öffentlich präsentiert.
Und da haben wir mal eine Zeit lang mit Kiosken zusammengearbeitet, aber das ist echt nicht besonders erträglich. Die Kioske wollten dann eine sehr hohe Marge haben. Dann ist die Vertriebslogistik eine ganz andere, die kommen nicht zu uns, um die Zeitschriften abzuholen, sondern man muss die natürlich abfahren und immer wieder neue Hefte vorbeibringen und die einzelne Abrechnung machen und das gesamte System Backoffice sozusagen, was hinter einer Straßenzeitung steckt, funktioniert da nicht. Und wir wollen ja auch nicht die Verkäufer verunsichern, indem wir andere Kanäle aufmachen.
Ja kann ich auch sehr gut nachvollziehen. Aber was vielleicht eine Idee gewesen wäre ist, die Studenten sozusagen an der Stelle auch mal als Verkäufer einzusetzen. Weil das ist ja quasi dann der einzige Erfahrungsbereich, der noch fehlt und der ja am Anfang schon eine Menge gebracht hat, als man mal angefangen hat, diesen Kanal auch zu befahren.
Alle Seetouristik Studierenden, die bevor sie in die Zeitung der Straße einsteigen müssen einen Tag mit Streetworkern im Bus durch die Gegend fahren und halt die ganzen Leute, die auf der Straße leben, die werden dann besucht und wird Kaffee ausgeschenkt und es werden Schlafsäcke verteilt oder es werden Leute für ärztliche Behandlungen abgeholt. Und das ist schon eine Grenzerfahrung für manche Studierende und die sprechen … Das ist wirklich eine Transformation, wie man sich selbst sieht und wie man die Gesellschaft sieht, auf einmal ist alles anders nach diesem Tag. Wir haben es schon öfter versucht, Studierende auch die Zeitschrift verkaufen zu lassen, aber das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Warum? Weil die werden für Messehostessen oder für Theaterprogrammverteiler gehalten. Weil das Genre Straßenmagazin funktioniert nur, wenn jemand entsprechend abgerissen auf der Straße steht und das anbietet.
Ansonsten erkennen die Leute gar nicht was das sein soll. Also das Genre braucht auch den Kontext. Und ein Straßenmagazin von gut gekleideten, gekämmten und geduschten Studierenden das irritiert nur. Ich habe es auch schon probiert, das ist ein echt hartes Geschäft.[00:51:53-1 @timpritlove>Okay.
Nochmal mein Ziel war, eine Lernumgebung zu schaffen, die wirtschaftliches Entscheiden und wirtschaftliches Handeln als Lernenden Lernaktivitäten ermöglicht. Lernumgebung die aber stärker unter unserer Kontrolle ist, als es eine externe Organisation tun kann. Und im Laufe der Zeit, wir haben jetzt ich glaube 150 Journalismus-Studis durchgehen lassen. Es waren glaube ich 80 Designer, Fotografen, 40 Seetouristiker, also Wirtschaftsstudis. Über 750 Straßenverkäufer bereits im Laufe der Zeit die sich im Verkauf versucht haben. Einige sind da geblieben, viele merken, es ist eben doch anstrengend. Ja es ist anstrengend. Oder sind halt im Knast oder müssen wieder irgendeine Therapie machen, also alles mögliche passiert da.
Also auf die Weise ist doch im Laufe der Jahre ein beträchtlicher Impact entstanden. Hat sehr sehr viele Leute erreicht. Die Auflage ist 10.000 für ein Studiprojekt. 10 Ausgaben im Jahr. Also wir haben da ein Zielumsatz von 100.000 Euro im Straßenverkauf plus Anzeigenerlöse und so weiter. Also das ist schon eine beträchtliche Sache. Aber, und das hatte ich am Anfang nicht so realisiert, je professioneller die Zeitschrift wird, desto weniger Spielraum bleibt für die Studierenden.
Weil die ihr Format gefunden hat und nicht mehr so …
Genau die Prozesse sind dann eingeschliffen und definiert und es ist alles Deadline-getrieben. Es muss ganz verlässlich sein. Wir können uns nicht erlauben, mal eine Ausgabe eine Woche später rauszubringen, wie wir es am Anfang mal gemacht haben. Weil einfach die Verkäufer ganz fest, also die brauchen einen verlässlichen Partner, einen verlässlichen Rahmen. Die brauchen Vorhersagbarkeit, ganz ganz wichtig. Ansonsten sind die sehr schnell verunsichert und das schränkt eben schon ein, was an Lernerfahrungen in der Zwischenzeit bei der Zeitschrift möglich ist. Deswegen meine Perspektive ist, wahrscheinlich so in zwei Jahren oder so, werden alle Kernfunktionen professionalisiert sein und Studierende können andocken mit Projekten, die aber nicht essentiell sind, sondern zusätzliche Aktivitäten sind.
Und das wirft natürlich die Fragen auf, wie erfahren Studierende im Rahmen des Studiums Selbstwirksamkeit, wenn selbst so ein Projekt im Laufe der Zeit eigentlich seine eigenen Spielräume einschränkt. Und das was mich im Moment so ein bisschen beschäftigt in der Richtung ist, sollte Studierenden nicht bereits im Laufe des Studiums ihre eigenen Unternehmen oder Initiativen oder so was ins Leben rufen in Teams? Und damit ihre eigenen Spielräume sich schaffen? Und diese Aktivitäten möglichst auch über das Studium hinaus beibehalten. Und das schwebt mir als Studiengang sogar vor. Ein Studiengang, bei dem die Studierenden bereits ganz zu Beginn des Studiums Unternehmen gründen und dann anhand der Unternehmensgründung lernen, wie so was funktioniert.
Stellen Sie sich vor, eine Truppe von 10 Studierenden gründet ein Unternehmen, überlegt sich, was können wir ohne viel Entwicklung anbieten einem Unternehmen beispielsweise, um ersten Umsatz zu erzielen? Also einen keinen Event organisieren oder eine kleine Marktforschung oder so was. Wofür man nicht so viel Vorbereitung braucht. Und dann machen die das und dann machen sie damit dann vielleicht 2.000 Euro Umsatz und dann kommt die Frage, wie verbucht man den eigentlich? Oh wir brauchen eine Buchhaltung. Wie baut man eine Buchhaltung auf? Und das ist auf einmal eine ganz andere Situation, als wenn auf dem Vorlesungsplan steht Buchhaltung. Sondern dann gibt es einen persönlichen Grund, sich das beizubringen, SICH das beizubringen, nicht beibringen zu lassen.
Vor allem man versteht auch sofort den Kontext der Dringlichkeit solcher Themen. Also so, ja das ist jetzt unvermeidlich, das ist nicht so eine Option, die man sich zu seiner Kreuzfahrt dazu bucht, da machen wir auch nochmal eine Woche Ausflug in Afrika, sondern man merkt, dass es essentieller Bestandteil ist, einfach aus dieser Unmittelbarkeit.
Ganz genau. Und das ist etwas was mir vorschwebt. In Finnland gibt es seit 30 Jahren oder so was bereits ein Studiengangsmodell, was genau so funktioniert. Komplett ohne Vorlesungen, wo die Lehre eigentlich nur ein Coaching ist und Studierende am eigenen Unternehmen lernen. Mittlerweile hat sich dieses Modell in 10 Ländern an 31 Standorten etabliert, aber das gibt es noch nicht in Deutschland. Und Berlin bräuchte so was zum Beispiel nicht, da gibt es eh ganz viel Startup-Szene. Aber für etwas entlegenere Standorte, wie Bremen und Bremerhaven wäre das eine feine Sache.
Also im Prinzip ist das so Startup-Kunde?
Wobei der Schwerpunkt Lernen ist und nicht das Startup. Aber Startup ist eben das nützliche Nebenprodukt und idealerweise kommen hinterher Unternehmen raus, die auch weiter bestehen. Aber es geht darum, wie lerne ich für einen Beruf in wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhängen so, dass es mir plausibel ist was passiert und warum ich das lernen muss. Genau wie Sie gerade gesagt haben. Rechnungswesen und Buchhaltung sind so Bereiche, da gähnen die meisten BWL-Studierenden, damit können gerade mal Anfang des Studiums, weil es als ein Grundlagenfach verstanden wird, nichts anfangen. Wenn sie aber ihr eigenes Unternehmen haben und gezwungen ihren Umsatz zu verbuchen, das ist was andres. Oder denken wir den nächsten Schritt. Dieses studentische Unternehmen hat einen potenziellen Kunden, aber um ihn bedienen zu können, müssen sie sich irgendwas kaufen, irgendeine Investition tätigen, einen Lasercutter oder weiß der Kuckuck.
So und dann muss die Entscheidung getroffen werden, wollen wir das Geld, was wir jetzt auf der hohen Kante haben, investieren oder wollen wir uns das irgendwann auszahlen? Und die Diskussion, die ist auch ganz klassisch im Unternehmen. Was sind unsere Ansprüche, damit wir investieren? Wann investieren wir? Wie entscheiden wir überhaupt? Konsens, Mehrheit, also wer entscheidet? Und all diese Fragen sind einfach verbunden mit so einer Unternehmensgründung. Wer ist unser Kunde? Ist Kunde König oder ist das Konzept König, an dem wir entwickeln? So was in der Richtung das fände ich nochmals spannend. Das ist so eine Art Konsequenz für mich aus der Erfahrung mit der Straßenzeitung, das wenn ein Unternehmen oder ein Lernunternehmen auch mal so stabil läuft, dass man sich kaum mehr traut, es anzufassen, weil einfach so viele Leute davon abhängen.
Dann hat es so ein bisschen seinen ursprünglichen Zweck verloren und da müssen wir uns weiterentwickeln.
Aber abgesehen jetzt von der Weiterentwicklung des Studiengangs ist ja jetzt auch dieses soziale Engagement  bei Ihnen weiterhin ein Thema geblieben. Jetzt haben wir die Erfahrung mit der Zeitschrift gesehen, die im Prinzip erst mal am Anfang eigentlich alles erfüllt hat, was man wollte. Man musste etwas komplett neu aufbauen, entwickeln, man hat die ganzen Spannungen gesehen, man hat aber auch interdisziplinäres Arbeiten gesehen. Und man hat vor allem eben auch eine unmittelbare Verbindung der Hochschule mit der Gesellschaft, und zwar eben auch konkret mit der Bremerhavener Problemrealität locker hergestellt. Jetzt ist das so ein bisschen abgeschliffen und führt sein eigenes Leben. Jetzt gibt es ja ein neues Projekt, was wieder versucht, die Universität und die soziale Realität zusammenzubringen. Die Universität der Straße. Also nach der Zeitschrift jetzt gleich eine ganze Universität auf der Straße. Was steckt dahinter? Was war da die Triebfeder?
Ja also das Projekt heißt die Uni der Straße. Universität hätten wir es glaube ich nicht nennen dürfen, weil es ein geschützter Begriff ist. Das ist die Uni der Straße. Die Uni der Straße ist ein Bildungsprogramm für Leute auf der Straße. Und in dem ist es auf Neudeutsch Spinoff der Zeitschrift. Da steckt der Gedanke oder die Erfahrung dahinter, dass die Verkäufer auf der Straße einen Zeithorizont haben, der häufig genau einen Tag beträgt. Viele unserer Verkäufer fangen morgens bei 0 Euro an, schnorren sich den ersten Euro zusammen, kommen dann ins Vertriebsbüro, kaufen sich eine Ausgabe der Zeitschrift, verkaufen die für 2 Euro, kommen ins Vertriebsbüro, kaufen sich zwei Ausgaben und verkaufen die für 4 Euro. Die fangen jeden Tag bei 0 an. Warum? Weil ihr Zeithorizont tatsächlich so ist.
Für die lohnt es sich kaum, an den nächsten Tag zu denken. Erstens weil auch Leute, die auf der Straße leben, die werden oft beklaut. Also es wird viel Kriminalität untereinander betrieben. Aber auch weil jeder Tag wie der andere ist. Also es ist eine Lebenswelt, die extrem klein ist. Die sich um wenige Straße, wenige Menschen, wenige Themen und ganz wenig Zeit dreht. Das ist die Lebenswelt der meisten Verkäufer auf der Straße und auch der meisten Wohnungslosen. Oder ich muss vorsichtig sein, die Leute zumindest, mit denen wir zu tun haben. Und indem wir denen jetzt einmal die Woche eine Veranstaltung anbieten zu einem Thema, das überwiegend nichts mit ihnen zu tun hat, aber eben in relativ kleinem Kreis. So dass es nicht anonym ist, sondern eigentlich eine sehr persönliche Veranstaltung. Auf die Weise hoffen wir, sie aus diesem sehr engen Horizont mal rausblicken zu lassen.
Ihre enge Lebenswelt aufzubrechen. Inspiration zu geben, vielleicht Interessen zu wecken, Erinnerungen wachzurufen an ihre Kindheit vielleicht, in der sie noch Hoffnungen hatten und Interessen. Vielleicht wollte jemand Naturwissenschaftler werden, aber es ist irgendwie ganz anders gelaufen. Dann haben wir Veranstaltungen beispielsweise zum Thema Gesundheit. Evidenzbasierte Medizin war eine Veranstaltung in diesem Semester. Ich habe etwas zur Geldpolitik, zum aktuellen Funktionieren des Geldsystems gemacht. Der Präsident des Amtsgerichts in Bremerhaven. Also wirklich Topleute, die das machen. Die einfach Interesse haben auch an dem Austausch mit den Leuten, die auf der Straße leben. Hat etwas über Insolvenzverfahren mit denen gemacht. Dann ein richtiges Highlight, es gibt in Bremen eine Action-Samba-Truppe, die auf Demos gehen und als Form des Widerstands Samba spielen.
Und mit denen wurde dann tatkräftig getrommelt und dann gab es eine Stadtführung über Widerstand im Nationalsozialismus, kam super an. Waren wir ganz skeptisch am Anfang.
Woran macht sich das fest? An der Teilnehmerzahl?
An der Resonanz. Teilnehmerzahl kann man jetzt nicht so als Maß nehmen, weil wir jetzt gerade erst damit angefangen haben. Wir haben jetzt quasi unser 0. Semester, unser Pilotsemester abgeschlossen. Das wollen wir jetzt einfach über die nächsten Jahre im Semesterrhythmus etablieren und wenn sich das mal stärker rumspricht, wir haben überhaupt noch keine Werbung gemacht. Also nur in einigen Wohnungslosenunterkünften schon, aber wir haben jetzt keine öffentliche Werbeaktion oder so gemacht, weil wir möchten, dass das Ganze einen geschützten Rahmen bietet, damit die Leute, die eh gesellschaftlich geprügelt sind nicht auch noch verdrängt werden von wissensdurstigen Volkshochschulbesuchern. Da gibt es schon irgendwie die Gefahr.
Aber im Prinzip steht die Teilnahme jedem frei zunächst einmal?
Genau, es gibt ein Anmeldeverfahren, damit wir ungefähr wissen wie viele Leute kommen. Und die Teilnehmerzahl schwankt so zwischen 8-15 im Moment. Und durch diese kleine Zahl kriegt man einfach richtig gute Gespräche hin. Die Referenten werden von uns so gebrieft, dass ihre Aufgabe es ist am Anfang vielleicht 5 oder 10 Minuten Impuls zu geben und dann entwickelt sich tatsächlich bereits Dynamik. Also anders als Studierende, die erst mal alles hinnehmen was man ihnen sagt, es nicht hinterfragen, vielleicht auch höchstens fragen, ist das klausurrelevant, kommt bei den Leuten, mit denen wir es bei der Uni der Straße zu tun haben, völlig ungefiltertes Erstaunen, Empörung und alles. Also das ist echt super. Mir hat das einen Höllenspaß gemacht. Ich habe noch nie eine so lebhafte Veranstaltung erlebt wie bei mir über Geldpolitik, ist das irre.
Was kommen da so für Rückfragen?
Naja also was eigentlich tatsächlich wenig Leute wissen ist, dass wenn Banken einen Kredit vergeben, dass sie das Geld, das sie da als Kredit vergeben, in dem Moment selber schaffen. Das gab es vorher nicht. Es ist nicht so, dass da Einlagen von Kunden an andere verliehen werden.
Es werde Geld, das Fiat-Geld
Genau, also praktisch darum ging es eigentlich, was ist eigentlich Schuldgeld. Und meinen Vortag oder meine Veranstaltung hatte ich betitelt, kein Geld ohne Schulden. Das war natürlich auch eine Anspielung auf die Lebenssituation der Verkäufer, weil die auch meistens verschuldet sind und wenn sie sich nicht verschulden haben sie kein Geld. Aber da war Empörung, und was ist wenn ich meinen Kredit nicht zurückzahle? Dann verlieren die doch gar nichts, weil da war doch auch schon nichts. Natürlich, genau das sind die Diskussionen, die eigentlich auch in der Bevölkerung durchaus mehr Raum haben könnten. Das ist schon, ich weiß nicht ob man das sagt, aber was ist schon der Überfall einer Bank gegen die Gründung einer Bank. Auf jeden Fall die Uni der Straße ist ein weiteres Experiment. Auch wieder ein Rahmen, um Studierende und Leute aus einem völlig anderem Milieu miteinander interagieren zu lassen.
Studierende organisieren das. Sind natürlich auch immer ein bisschen dabei, aber halten sich ganz arg im Hintergrund. Ja also aufregend, sehr aufregend und immer wieder voller Überraschungen.
Aber die Uni der Straße ist eigentlich mehr ein Projekt für die Uni selbst? Nicht so sehr jetzt wie bei der Zeitschrift für den Studiengang, für die Studierenden?
Die Uni der Straße ist in erster Linie ein Projekt für Leute auf der Straße.
Okay ich habe es falsch herum formuliert. Also von der Uni für Leute der Straße. Aber es ist sozusagen mehr ein Thema der Uni als solcher und nicht so sehr es ist jetzt kein studentisch organisiertes Projekt?
Naja, das Semesterprogramm wird weitgehend von den Studierenden entwickelt. Auch basierend auf Interviews, sowohl mit Einrichtungsleitungen, die Wohnungsloseneinrichtungen betreuen. Als auch mit Teilnehmern der Uni der Straße, als auch mit Interviews mit Verkäufern.
Okay also es hat sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon aus dem Zeitschriftprojekt mit heraus entwickelt.
Ja das ist ein eigenes Team, was das macht. Genau das sind auch ganz andere Aufgaben. Aber es ist kein Sozialunternehmen. Es generiert keine eigenen Erlöse, anders als die Zeitschrift.
Ist ein Bildungsprojekt.
Damit ist es auf Fördermittel angewiesen. Aktion Mensch macht das erst mal für drei Jahre und danach müssen wir sehen, wie wir es weiter finanziert kriegen. Also ob das durch Spenden oder so aufrechterhalten werden kann. Denn wir haben dafür auch einen halben Mitarbeiter, der halt immer da ist, um sich um Räume und die ganze Logistik und Anmeldungen und all das zu kümmern, was halt jetzt auch nötig ist. Aber trotzdem auch hier wieder, es ist ein gestaltbarer Raum für Studierende mit einem gesellschaftlichen Mehrwert. Und vielleicht führt uns das jetzt mal noch dazu, dass wir vielleicht den Diskussionshorizont ein bisschen weiter aufspannen Und von dem einzelnen Projekt mal weggehen. Ich frage mich zum Beispiel, wie sich Hochschulen auf die Gesellschaft oder auf die Makroentwicklung der Gesellschaft einstellen.
Wir sehne beispielsweise seit vielen vielen Jahren ein Abnehmen von Wahlbeteiligung. Wir sehen, dass Politikern immer weniger Vertrauen entgegen gebracht wird. Dass mittlerweile Politiker bedroht, beschimpft und sogar mit Tod bedroht werden für relative Nichtigkeiten. Dass da eine politische Kultur sich im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt und vielleicht auch befördert durch die sozialen Medien, die eigentlich nach einer Veränderung von Debattenkultur und vielleicht auch von Rollenverteilungen in der Gesellschaft, was dafür spricht, darüber mal nachzudenken. Jetzt Hochschulen in Deutschland sind fast alle staatlich, wir haben ganz wenige Privathochschulen. Also das Bildungssystem ist staatlich geprägt. Und die meisten Studiengänge bereiten, spätestens seit Bologna, auf irgendeinen Beruf vor.
Das heißt wir haben den Staat, der für den Markt vorbereitet, aber Politik als Raum zur Willensbildung, zur Entscheidungsfindung, zur Auseinandersetzung, Öffentlichkeit, dieser gesamte Raum, der ist davon erst mal nicht tangiert. Und ich frage mich, ob künftig einfach Zivilgesellschaft nicht eine sehr sehr viel größere Rolle in der Gesellschaft zukommen muss, weil die Politik immer weniger in der Lage ist, der Komplexität Herr zu werden. Weil der Staat vielleicht auch immer weniger Möglichkeiten hat, all das zu leisten, was er in der Vergangenheit versprochen hat. Und vor dem Hintergrund sehe ich Projekte, wie die Zeitschrift der Straße oder all die Aktivitäten, die die Hochschulen unternehmen, um ihren Studierenden erste Erfahrungen im zivilgesellschaftlichen Engagement zu erlauben, zu ermöglichen, die halte ich für sehr wichtig, was die Gestaltung unserer Gesellschaft angeht.
Und der Stifterverband fördert solche Aktivitäten in letzter Zeit verstärkt, aber ich denke die meisten Hochschulen, allein durch ihre Bolognalastigkeit, durch ihre Orientierung an Employability, an Beschäftigungsfähigkeit oder auch durch ihren Fachdisziplinenblick auf die Welt machen da zu wenig. Also aus meiner Sicht sollten Hochschulen sehr viel stärker entweder Akteure der Zivilgesellschaft werden oder sich als solche verstehen oder zumindest Akteure für die Zivilgesellschaft entwickeln helfen.
Ist ja auch ein Thema, was hier schon in mehreren Gesprächen bei Forschergeist immer wieder aufgekommen ist in der einen oder anderen Form. Ich interpretier jetzt auch das worüber wir mal gesprochen haben, im Prinzip als so eine Art erweiterte Interdisziplinarität. Bisher wenn man von Interdisziplinarität sprechen und von wissenschaftlicher Forschung dann meinen wir, Blick über den eigenen Fachbereich hinaus, Vernetzung mit anderen Disziplinen, um einfach auch überhaupt erst an neue Erkenntnisse so zu geraten, weil es sich einfach herausgestellt hat, dass das eben sehr schwierig ist, wenn man das nicht mit in den Blick rein nimmt, überhaupt noch angemessen zu forschen. Aber wir sprechen ja im Prinzip von einer Interdisziplinarität, die eben dann eben auch die Grenzen der Hochschulen im Prinzip überschreitet und die Gesellschaft selbst mit einbindet, die Stadt mit einbindet und dort eine ganz andere Verankerung eigentlich auch des Lehrbetriebs in der Gesellschaft mit zur Folge hat.
Der Begriff, Entschuldigung, dass ich kurz reingrätsche, der Begriff Interdisziplinarität ist ja nur ein Hilfskonstrukt innerhalb der Hochschule, weil Disziplinen gibt es ja außerhalb der Hochschule überhaupt nicht. Also das ist ja eine rein innenwissenschaftliche Kategorisierung, die halt tradiert ist, aber außerhalb von Hochschule spricht man doch nicht von Disziplinen, sondern da hat man ein Problem und muss halt alle Aspekte des Problems irgendwie miteinander vernetzt sehen und so zu einer Lösung kommen. Hochschulen fragmentieren Probleme nach Kriterien, die außerhalb der Hochschule irrelevant sind. Es ist irrelevant, also kein Problem ist ein reines Ingenieurproblem, außer man hat es schon so zurechtgestutzt, dass es nur noch ein Ingenieurproblem ist. Sondern es ist immer auch ein Eingriff in irgendwie menschliches Leben, wenn eine Brücke gebaut wird. Und es ist immer auch ein ökonomisches Thema und es ist dann möglicherweise auch ein ökologisches Thema.
Insofern gibt es in der Realität eigentlich kein Problem, das sich auf eine Disziplin beschränkt. Es sind nur die Hochschulen, die so denken. Und dann über Interdisziplinarität zu sprechen impliziert, dass man sich weiterhin innerhalb der Hochschule bewegt. Genau, aber ich gebe Ihnen völlig recht, die Grenze zwischen Hochschule und nicht Hochschule ist einfach viel viel zu dick, zu unüberwindlich. Was auch damit zusammenhängt, wie beispielsweise Reputation im Hochschulbereich erzeugt, gemessen wird und dass dann halt ein großes Drittmittel-Forschungsprojekt, das sich mit einem Thema beschäftigt, dass in der Wissenschaft eine große Bedeutung hat, mit einem viel höheren Impact-Factor ausgestattet ist, wenn es dann publiziert ist, als ein Projekt, wie zum Beispiel das Straßenmagazin, das für hunderte von armen Menschen auf der Straße einen ganz großen Impact hat, aber in der innenwissenschaftlichen Community einen Impact von null.
Wenn sich jetzt eine Hochschule entscheidet zu sagen, okay für uns gibt es jetzt nicht Bologna-Prozess und wir kennen zwar die Zwänge und die Zwänge sind stark, aber wir wollen uns trotzdem öffnen und wir denken zum Beispiel über solche Modelle wie Uni der Straße nach, die ja im Prinzip einerseits eine Dienstleistung an den Studenten ist, wie hier bekommt ihr Kontakt quasi mit der Welt, die ist auch für euer Arbeiten wichtig. Andererseits kann euer Lernen in dem Moment eben auch positive Effekte erzielen, weil ihr im Prinzip auch etwas zurückgebt. Ähnliche Ideen verfolgen ja auch schon diese Volkshochschulen, die ja eigentlich so in den normalen Hochschulbetrieb überhaupt nicht mit eingebunden sind. Lässt sich da vielleicht so ein gemeinsames Gedankenmodell daraus ableiten, wie eigentlich diese Verflechtungen künftig organisiert sein sollte?
Ich stelle mir vor, das sind die Leute, die in der Uni der Straße sind, erarbeiten die sich jetzt mehr als nur ein paar erkenntnisreiche Gespräche, sondern können die sozusagen in diesen Prozess sich auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Qualifikation im Kleinen schaffen, die sie vielleicht auch konkret weiterbringen? Volkshochschulen, ich habe persönlich nicht so viele Erfahrungen damit, gibt es ja unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber, wie viel Qualität das wirklich in die Gesellschaft zurückbringt. Sollte es vielleicht mehr Durchlässigkeit generell geben und brauchen wir dann vielleicht ein anderes, noch ein zusätzliches Modell oder nur eine andere Vernetzung der existierenden Modelle?
Also die Struktur eines Bildungssystems machen wir jetzt gerade zum Gesprächsgegenstand.
Wir erfinden jetzt einfach mal alles neu.
Also klar, eine große Schwierigkeit glaube ich in Deutschland speziell ist die Art der Bildungsfinanzierung. Im Hochschulbereich, also Hochschulen werden öffentlich finanziert. Und private Herausforderer müssen sich nicht nur durch ein mindestens so gutes Bildungsangebot hervortun, sondern das muss auch noch so deutlich besser sein oder anders, dass sich auch Studiengebühren dafür einnehmen lassen. Das heißt, was normalerweise im Innovationswettbewerb funktioniert, dass dann ein Newcomer zwar erst mal erklären muss, was er neu macht, aber ansonsten schon unter gleichen Bedingungen in den Markt eintritt, haben wir im Bildungssektor nicht. Innovationen haben es da wahnsinnig schwer, wenn sie nicht innerhalb des staatlich finanzierten Hochschulsystem stattfinden.
Volkshochschulen haben ja einen ganz anderen Anspruch. Das ist mehr dran am lebenslangen Lernen, nicht auf ein bestimmtes Zertifikat Abschlussorientierung hin überwiegend. Und es gibt eine ganze Reihe Hochschullehrer, die auch nebenher an Fachhochschulen unterrichten. Aber was mir in Deutschland eigentlich fehlt wäre eine Finanzierung von Bildung über Bildungsgutscheine. Meinetwegen Bildung kann weiterhin frei sein, kostenlos sein, Studierende, Studierwillige kriegen Bildungsgutscheine und können die dorthin tragen, wo die gerne sich bilden möchten, und auf die Weise vielleicht auch ganz abgefahrene oder innovative Modelle zur Existenz oder zu Wachstum verhelfen.
Diejenigen Hochschulen, die halt dann keine Nachfrage mehr haben, vielleicht auch aus gutem Grund, die müssen sich was überlegen.
Wo könnten diese Gutscheine herkommen?
Nein ich meine, man könnte ja sagen zum Beispiel, Hochschulen kriegen eine Grundfinanzierung ein Stück weit, also eine Auskömmlichkeit auf deutlich niedrigerem Niveau ermöglicht. Und dann gibt es einen Topf, der heute bereits in der Hochschulfinanzierung verwendet wird, der dann quasi umgewandelt wird in Gutscheine. Der Staat zahlt also weiterhin für Bildung. Aber die Lernenden entscheiden, wohin das Geld fließt, indem sie die Gutscheine dann dort abgeben. Solche Modelle wurden auch schon in der Vergangenheit diskutiert. Weil worauf ich nur hinaus will ist, es ist wahnsinnig schwierig für ganz anders funktionierende Bildungsmodelle in Deutschland Fuß zu fassen. Ich bin beispielsweise seit zwei Jahren, also mehr am Rande eigentlich involviert, in ein Hochschulgründungsprojekt an der Mosel.
In Bernkastel-Kues. Da hat sich eine Hochschule formiert, eine private Hochschule.
Cusanus-Hochschule.
Genau, und zwar aus einer Kritik heraus. Eine Kritik an einer bestehenden ökonomischen Bildung. Weil die ökonomische Bildung relativ dogmatisch ist, sehr stark eine bestimmte Denkschule in sich aufgenommen hat und andere Denkschulen, die es auf jeden Fall in der Vergangenheit immer wieder gab und immer noch gibt, marginalisiert. Und die Cusanus-Hochschule ist eine Gründung von Professoren/Professorinnen anderer Hochschulen, die gesagt haben, so wie es bei uns läuft, geht es nicht mehr. Wir machen jetzt unser eigenes Ding. Und dort gibt es einen geisteswissenschaftlichen Zugang zu Wirtschaftswissenschaften zum Beispiel. Finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr sehr sehr wertvoll und wichtig für den Diskurs in der Gesellschaft. Praktisch die Historizität von Ökonomie zum Beispiel zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Aber die müssen den Hochschulbetrieb halt aus Studiengebühren finanzieren. Und das ist ganz schön schwierig.
Wenn überall Ökonomie-Studiengänge angeboten werden, die nichts kosten den Studierenden nichts kosten, dann muss man schon echt ein ganz besonderer Typ sein, um dann zu sagen, ich zahle da meine 600 Euro im Monat oder ich habe ein Stipendium, aber 600 Euro im Monat, um dort meinen Master in Ökonomie zu machen, weil ich denke, dass dieser spezielle Zugang zu Ökonomie wichtig ist. Diese Form von Innovation kommt kaum zustande in einem System, das immer nur das Bestehende finanziert. Und bei dem Newcomer nicht nur damit zu kämpfen haben, sich bekannt zu machen, sondern auch sich zu finanzieren. Da würde ich mir was anderes wünschen.
Wie zum Beispiel so einen Gutscheinmodell.
Genau.
Müsste man sich natürlich gut Gedanken darüber machen, wer dann an der Stelle dann wirklich auch Begünstigter sein könnte.
Nein alle. Also jeder, zum Beispiel mit der Hochschulzugangsberechtigung erhält man seine Gutscheine.
Nein ich meine, wer sie sozusagen annehmen darf. Die Seite gibt es ja auch noch. Nicht dass dann gleich so eine Chemtrails-Universität aufmacht.
Nein man kann ja durchaus das bestehende Verfahren nutzen, was der Wissenschaftsrat, die Institut quasi ihr Betriebsgenehmigung erteilt. Also irgendeine Form von Qualitätsaufsicht braucht es schon denke ich. Wenn es der Staat zahlt, dann muss der Staat auch einen Blick drauf haben können, also das finde ich schon in Ordnung.
Aber man kann es halt dahin tragen, wo man es für richtig hält.
Genau, aber die Diskriminierung zwischen privaten und staatlichen Anbietern, die finde ich halt vielfach schwierig. Wir haben, wenn man sich in der deutschen Hochschullandschaft die privaten Hochschulen anguckt, fast nur kleine Betriebswirtschafts- und Design- und ein bisschen Jurahochschulen. Warum? Weil Ökonomen und Juristen für ihre wissenschaftliche Tätigkeit ein Stift und ein Blatt Papier brauchen oder vielleicht ein paar Texte. Und des ist glaube ich nur Witten-Herdecke, die da auch Medizin beispielsweise anbieten, was sehr sehr viel teurer ist. Aber da sieht man einfach, dass private Hochschulgründungen eigentlich das Potenzial hätten zur Innovation. Zeppelin-Uni in Friedrichshafen oder Witten-Herdecke ist auf jeden Fall auch ein sehr innovatives Modell.
Das ist wahrscheinlich kein Zufall, dass es private Unis sind. Weil an öffentlichen Hochschulen das was die machen sehr viel schwerer etabliert hätte werden können. Weil Hochschulen reproduzieren sich ja selber. Und in anderen Ländern gibt es deswegen glaube ich mehr Dynamik, mehr Vielfalt in den Studienangeboten, aber auf der anderen Seite in Großbritannien zum Beispiel, wo sich der Staat zunehmend aus der Bildungsfinanzierung zurückzieht, treten ganz andere Probleme auf. Wenn man für einen Bachelor 9000 Pfund im Jahr zahlt, wird das auf einmal zu einem interessanten Geschäftsfeld und da tummeln sich Anbieter, die einfach 0815 Angebote machen und wissen, dass sie ihre zahlende Kundschaft kriegen. Das sei auch nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Bleibt schwierig.
Ja, aber ich finde schon, dass das aktuelle System der Diskriminierung zwischen privaten und staatlichen Anbietern bei uns ziemlich innovationshemmend ist. Gerade wenn die Gesellschaft sich sehr schnell ändert und die Hochschulen sich sehr langsam ändern, dann kann es eigentlich nicht im Interesse des Staates sein, diese sehr langsamere Entwicklung dauerhaft aufrecht zu erhalten.
Wenn wir vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal den Bogen spannen, nochmal zu dem was hier so ein bisschen auch der Auslöser für das Gespräch war, nämlich diese Verbindung wirklich mit dem anderen Ende der Gesellschaft. Auf der einen Seite die aufstrebenden bildungsfähigen, bildungswilligen Menschen, die sich dadurch natürlich auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten erarbeiten. Auf der anderen Seite Gruppen, die das für sich nicht für möglich halten oder eben auch aus anderen Gründen einfach überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit haben, jemals in diesen Bereich hineinzugeraten. Das miteinander zu verbinden und damit eben auch so diese Unterschiede aufzulösen. Wir wissen ja, dass Bildung im Prinzip so das einzige ist, was in der Lage ist, langfristig die Dinge dann auch nachhaltig zu ändern. Welche Ansätze könnte denn der Staat jetzt hier so aus Ihrer Erfahrungsperspektive heraus machen, um diese Abstände zu verringern?
Also ich bin jetzt eigentlich nicht so der Typ, der nach dem Staat ruft. Ich bin eher so der …
Oder die Gesellschaft, ich meine irgendjemand muss es ja umsetzen, aber was wären so die Ideenansätze, sagen wir es so?
Ich habe eigentlich mehr Vertrauen in die innovative Vielfalt und auch ein bisschen den Wettbewerb der Konzepte nebeneinander. Vor zwei Jahren habe ich mal versucht, das Modell der Zeitschrift der Straße zu verallgemeinern. Habe mir überlegt, wie könnte das eigentlich aussehen, dass Studierende lernen und gleichzeitig einen gesellschaftlichen Beitrag leisten in einer Weise, dass dadurch ein Geschäftsmodell möglich wird. Ein Geschäftsmodell bedeutet, dass das was man tut eigentlich nachhaltig fortgeführt werden kann, weil es einen Umsatz generiert, der nötig ist, das was ich gerade tue fortzuführen. Also deswegen das Sozialunternehmertum hat den großen Vorteil gegenüber spendenfinanzierten sozialen Projekten, das soziale Unternehmertun immer den Umsatz dazu benutzen kann, um weiter an der sozialen Problemlösung zu arbeiten.
Und quasi durch das eigene Tun ständig die Ressourcen neu generiert. Meine Überlegung war, das hatte ich damals irgendwie mit dem Begriff „Compreneurship“ versehen. Studierende und in irgendeiner Weise benachteiligte Menschen arbeiten und lernen zusammen, ein Unternehmen zu betreiben. Das erschien mir eigentlich als ein ganz raffiniertes Modell. Wenn Studierende vor allem im Rahmen des Studiums ein Unternehmen gründen und dann eben Beratungsleistung anbieten, dann gibt es sehr schnell den Vorwurf der Marktverzerrung. Denn natürlich Studierende werden niemals die Preise verlangen, haben aber weil sie Prüfungsleistungen erbringen und der Prof mit dahintersteckt und vielleicht das Knowhow des Profs noch mit rein fließt und so, schon normalerweise ein ganz gutes Produkt, das sie abliefern können.
Aber zu unvergleichlich geringen Preisen. Machen dadurch den Markt kaputt. Wenn man aber diese studentischen Lerninitiativen, Lernunternehmen so konstruiert, dass von Vornherein auch Leute, die am ersten Arbeitsmarkt benachteiligt sind, mit eingebaut werden. Also das können Leute sein, die mit Behinderungen …
Was es ja auch gibt, so Behindertenwerkstätten ähnliche Modelle.
Genau, Integrationsbetriebe. Aber die gibt es eigentlich nicht als studentische Unternehmen. Praktisch die Subventionen, die die Hochschule im studentischen Unternehmen darstellt, zu kompensieren durch den Nachteil, Leute mit Nachteil im ersten Arbeitsmarkt mit einzubauen. Es können auch Langzeitarbeitslose sein. Es können zum Beispiel Mütter sein, die lange Zeit aus dem Beruf raus waren und wieder reinkommen möchten. Einfach alle Leute, die irgendeinen Wettbewerbsnachteil haben.
Alter.
Alter auf jeden Fall ja genau. Oder eben im Extremfall, Leute die sogar auf der Straße leben. Und wo sich dann der Vorteil der Energie, der Lebenslust, der Kreativität und vielleicht auch der Qualität der Arbeit der Studierenden mit den Nachteilen der anderen so ein bisschen die Waage hält. Dass dann diese beiden Gruppen lernen miteinander umzugehen und dass das schon ein Lernprozess ist, der über das fachliche Lernen und das Lernen ein Unternehmen zu betreiben hinausgeht und in Form von gesellschaftlicher Kohäsion, zumindest im Kleinen, generiert. Und Compreneurship da stecken so Begriffe wie Community/Gemeinschaft drin, Comprehension/gegenseitiges Verstehen, Competence/Fachkompetenz, all das steckt in dem Begriff Compreneurship drin.
Aber nach den Erfahrungen, die ich jetzt mit der Zeitschrift gesammelt habe denke ich bräuchten die Hochschulen, um so was zu ermöglichen, anderes Personal. Also Profs sind ehrlich gesagt für so was die falschen Leute. Man müsste zumindest auch Sozialarbeiter oder irgendwelche speziell geschulten Betreuer oder praxiserfahrene Coaches dabei haben. Professoren sind eigentlich für die Aufgaben, die die Hochschulen im Bereich der Zivilgesellschaft haben, eher nicht so klassische Lehre und klassische Forschung sind, sind Professoren eigentlich so ein bisschen fehlqualifiziert.
Ja.
Also gerade das Bewusstsein Experte zu sein ist häufig sehr störend, gerade wenn es um grenzüberschreitendes Arbeiten geht.
Fällt mir ja wieder nochmal die Talentförderung ein, die ja im Prinzip genau so ein neues Instrument in der Universität auch installiert hat, eben speziell diesen Bereich der Talentförderung. Wenn man jetzt sagen würde, es gibt genauso eine Abteilung für zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement, was genau diese Leute zusammenholt, Sozialarbeiter und all die anderen Felder, die wir jetzt berührt haben, zusammenzieht in so einem Kompetenzteam, die dann wiederum anfangen, aus dieser Position heraus, aber schon mit Rückendeckung der Hochschule Studierende explizit dabei zu unterstützen, solche Projekte zu starten, wäre das vielleicht ein Modell?
Genau, also da bin ich auch relativ eng verhandelt mit einem Projekt an der Uni Kiel, das interessanterweise ein Kollege aus der Geografie, ein Geografieprofessor, Christoph Corves ins Leben gerufen hat. Das ist wie so eine Art Inkubatorprogramm für studentische Sozialstartups. Die haben ein mehrstufiges Programm. Am Anfang steht ein Ideenwettbewerb, bei dem sich Studierende aller Fachgebiete mit Ideen für soziale Unternehmen melden können, die reichen ihr Konzept ein. Das Konzept durchläuft ein Jury-Bewertungsprogramm, die vielversprechendsten Konzepte werden dann mit Geld ausgezeichnet, werden gefördert. Die haben dort die Räume einer ehemaligen Kunsthochschule übernommen. Da ist eine Vielzahl von kleinen Werkstätten und Bürochen und so entstanden, wo tatsächlich Studierende als Teil oder vor allen Dingen neben ihrem Studium schon an Sozialunternehmen arbeiten. Und ganz unterschiedliche Art von Betreuung erhalten. Je nachdem, in welchem Bereich sie unterwegs sind.
Also Kieler School of Sustainability.
Genau. Also da steckt Christoph Korvis von der School of Sustainability steckt dahinter. Das Programm heißt Juwidu oder Zukunftsmacher.sh für Schleswig-Holstein. Das finde ich das ist aus meiner Sicht sehr vielversprechend, weil es den Studierenden den Freiraum gibt das zu machen, was sie selbst für richtig halten. Und weil die Studierenden mit ihren Projekten zusammen reifen. Das entspricht so ein bisschen der Idee des Studiengangs des Unternehmungsgründungsstudiengangs, den ich vorhin erwähnt habe. Nur dass die das halt mit sehr viel geringerem Zeiteinsatz und geringerem Mittelaufwand ein bisschen nebenher laufen lassen. Aber in die Richtung könnte ich mir vorstellen sollten Hochschulen verstärkt gehen. Die Initiative fördern, die Selbstwirksamkeit der Studierenden fördern. Auf Neudeutsch Empowerment. Ganz wichtig. Nicht drauf warten, dass die Studierenden im Lernen darin bestätigt werden, darauf zu warten, dass ihnen jemand sagt, was zu tun ist.
Und Zivilgesellschaft funktioniert eben nur durch Mitmachen und nur durch Machen. Und nicht drauf zu gucken, dass der Staat etwas unternimmt. Und da denke ich könnten Hochschulen viel mehr machen. Ich betrachte die Zeitschrift als einen Beitrag, aber eben auch als einen der gezeigt hat, wo auch die Grenzen sind, wenn ein Unternehmen dann mal einen bestimmten Reifegrad erreicht hat, dass dann Lernen zunehmend in den Hintergrund rückt.
Ja ich denke das bringt uns dann auch an das Ende dieses Gespräches Herr Vogel. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen. Ich finde das gleichsam notwendig wie auch das sind Schritte mit Potenzialen, die sozusagen das Lernen als solches oder sagen wir mal auch den Aufenthalt der Studenten an einer Schule eigentlich noch viel interessanter machen, als wenn man eben das wirklich nur sieht als, oh jetzt erlerne ich meinen Beruf, dann führe ich ihn aus and than you’ll die.
Da gibt es von Yunus, Muhammed Yunus, dem Mikrokredit-Erfinder und Friedensnobelpreisträger, da gibt es den Spruch, wieso verlassen Absolventen die Hochschule mit einer Bewerbungsmappe und nicht mit einem Businessplan? Bewerbungsmappe setzt voraus, dass irgendwo da draußen etwas ist, wo man sich einfach nur drandocken muss, aber Eigeninitiative ist gar nicht gefragt. Gerade bei den Wirtschaftsstudierenden ist es wirklich so, warum machen die nicht viel stärker ihr eigenes Ding und die Hochschulen sollten dazu einen Beitrag leisten.
Ja vielen Dank.
Gern.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war Forschergeist 32. Ausgabe und weitere Themen und auch das ein oder andere was heute hier schon sich abgezeichnet hat wird bei uns demnächst ein Thema sein und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.